[Musique]
et cet après midi déjeuner sur l'herbe
pour le dernier meeting de campagne de
françois bayrou ambiance bucolique mais
les phrases n'étaient pas amis leuze
jean baptiste preda liée à la langue est
chaud c'est une fin de campagne version
retour aux sources françois bayrou a
emmené quelques-uns de ses 86 colistiers
à la découverte du sud ouest entre béarn
et pays basque l'ultime occasion pour
lui de présenter les vedettes de sa
liste
aujourd'hui à bidache s'était résolument
champêtre et terroirs pendant trois mois
françois bayrou a sillonné la quasi
totalité de la france il en est persuadé
l'udf est maintenant identifiée reconnu
par les français
je crois que beaucoup reconnaissent qu'
on est une des seules listes voir
effectivement parlé d'europe à avoir mis
l'europe au centre de notre projet et
puis ils sentent qu'il ya là
une approche de la politique qui ne
ressemble pas aux autres l'europe au
centre du projet et l'avenir de la
droite comme enjeu pour dimanche et pour
la suite françois bayrou estime s'être
émancipé du rpr notamment il espère même
recueillir maintenant les fruits de son
affrontement direct avec nicolas sarkozy
mieux la vérité dans cette ambiance là
quand on n'a pas besoin de faire
semblant de rechercher des accords
d'appareil quand on est certain d'être
dans la sincérité l'honnêteté des
attitudes et en conformité en
authenticité avec ses choix l'épreuve de
vérité ce sera pour dimanche
pour françois bayrou l'important sera
surtout de démontrer qu'il peut peser
sur la suite en attendant les
européennes sa première vraie
compétition valait bien une chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]